what's that man your morning routine you
like elaborate more on that and like how
to be like consistent with it my morning
routine shifts every now and then I
think the important part of morning
routine is to figure out what sets you
up like what fires you up we can see you
going and then incorporate it and see
how it works out so for me most recently
I've been putting basketball into my
morning routine
I haven't played basketball in like 20
years and even following on IG I'm
playing basketball I go and I like I get
tired after 20 minutes I'm missing like
I'm missing 90 percent of the shots but
it's just fun it's a fun way to get out
and have some activity so I start my day
by doing that I wake up I usually look
at some inspiration and I share share my
own thoughts so I have like that
15-second black-and-white video that I
post on IG and Twitter and LinkedIn all
those places that's really like the
thing that I need the most I need to I
need to get inspired and then I need to
share and by doing those two things that
sets me up for the day so all in that
takes me I don't know five minutes to do
like find the quote usually I look at my
own book the top ten rules the success I
get on some some some path some idea and
then I'll share it today was about
momentum didn't come from my book it
came from me being sick yesterday and
and like I will not lose momentum today
has to be a great day so I'm carrying
that forward and that's the most
important part of my routine but from
there now I'm going to play basketball
my goal is to get like 45 minutes an
hour but I don't have the physical
stamina to do that yet so I play for
like 25 minutes sometimes half an hour
I'm working my way up and then subway
home go to Whole Foods grab a kombucha
and the salad and usually like a Tim
Hortons coffee and then I start work and
so I'm usually up at 7:00 and I'm back
by 10:00 and my first thing is 10 so
whether that's a call a meeting YouTube
videos so in those three hours that's
basically what I'm doing most of it
because basketball take some time to do
when the travel to get there and back on
the travel time I'm doing I'm doing
email I'm doing IG I'm getting I'm
getting work done while I'm traveling to
and from the basketball play
but really the thing for me that sets me
up is just getting inspired by something
and then sharing and that's that's the
most important five minutes of my day
every day that gets me set up for
success another thing I'm like
struggling with like is I think it's
just the consistency and I think it's
the routine I want to get into that this
summer and like so it's easier when I go
back to school and stuff like that cuz I
don't have obviously right now I school
to worry about or anything like that so
finding the routine staying and then
staying consistent with it and staying
you know this point about it and that's
and it's tough to do that the summer
because you know you don't really have
to get up for anything and you know you
kind of lazy with it and you can get
kind of get up whenever you want and
it's just tough for me I don't know I
just think it's the consistent trying to
stay consistent with the throughout so
what's the thing that you want to do
when your morning routine like what's
the most important element of the
morning routine that you want to do
daily getting up at a decent times that
I have the ability to you know go to the
gym or that kind of thing it's like I
don't have anything to really get up for
you know when I'm at school I have to
get up you know they go to class and
stuff like that so I think that's the
biggest thing is just I have so much
freedom right now it's really kind of
struggling
I guess so this is an exercise in
self-respect because if you are only
relying and waiting on external factors
to get you motivated in doing something
you're gonna lose forever it's about you
being able to motivate yourself and
respect yourself and have enough
self-confidence for yourself to go out
and do it to live the life that you want
to live what I would do is set a trigger
for the alarm clock so I would set my
alarm whatever time you want to wake up
9 o'clock 7 o'clock 8 o'clock like
whatever the time is and when the alarm
clock goes off like you get out of bed
and this is the signal to yourself that
the very first thing you did today was I
set a goal to wake up at 8 o'clock and I
did it and every time you hit the snooze
button or turn off the alarm you're
telling yourself it's ok not to hit your
goal but every time you get up and out
of bed and you do it then you're telling
you you're building the self-respect
right like I'm going to
my day today and the more that you do
that like if you did that I think that
the summer time is the best way to build
this habit the challenges difficulty is
it's easy to do it in the school year
because you have to get up you got class
you got a professor who's waiting on you
or students who you have to go meet
right this is the best time to build
that habit and once you start building
the habit it becomes it becomes part of
your routine or eventually you won't
even need to have to go through the
exercise it'll just be part of what you
do daily your hobby
you're about to go on the 30 days a
Klang challenge this is it and anybody
who wants to join in can join in the 30
days a Klang challenge
here's we do print off the calendar and
then every morning what time do you want
to wake up highlight seven okay so seven
so the Zach blank challenge every day
for the next thirty days you're gonna
wake up at 7 whatever else happens
during that day is okay you'll figure it
out but you got to be out of bed by 7
o'clock you print off the calendar and
every day you do it you put an X like I
did it I did this day I did this day X
and you can't miss a day for the next 30
days and whenever it's hard that's when
you train the self respect when when you
go to bed late like you're out partying
with your friends or you're watching you
know some some sporting event or
whatever and you're up late and then the
next day you still wake up at 7 o'clock
that's when you build the self-respect
that's when it's awesome this is the
this summer time where there's no
commitments is the best time to do it so
so mine I don't have to come and get out
of bed mine what I'm doing now is I I
fast until noon like I only have coffee
or a drink until noon and then I have to
do 30 minutes of cardio every day so
when I went to Boston by the time we got
settled in and everything it was it was
3:00 in the morning
we're like everybody's gonna go to bed
because we drove there after Nina's work
and settled in at 3 o'clock I had fasted
a day but I didn't do my run like guys
it's 3 o'clock we got to get up to go
meet people for coffee tomorrow morning
but I haven't done my run so I'm gonna
I'm gonna run on the spot for the next
30 minutes like when it's hard it's
that's the best that's when you're
trained like even if you're dead tired
that whole day
you're sinking you're telling yourself
it's it's the self-respect like I set a
goal it was impossibly hard and I did it
right and then just be smarter the next
day like what you'll not go into bed a
little early or the next day to recover
but when it's hard is when you set that
self-respect and so 30 days Act
challenge go build off but print off
that calendar every single day weekends
- for the next 30 days you're gonna wake
up at 7 o'clock and not go back to bed
and then your day will start here's the
thing whether you want to keep that
habit past 30 days is up to you it's got
to serve you like maybe you decide you
know what this isn't sustainable it's
not good like I want to wake up at 8
o'clock or whatever it is but when you
set a goal you have to be very careful
about the goals you set because when you
set a goal then you have to do that goal
so when you say you're gonna go
somewhere you have to go somewhere when
you say you're gonna you can make a IG
live video every day you have to make an
IG live video every day you're gonna
wake up at 7 you have to wake up at 7
and every time that you don't do it
you're you're eating away at your
self-respect put a thing on Facebook my
mom can't yell at me she's like you
don't need to put out all your business
and stuff but it was about like my
weight loss and you know one they get
back in shape and stuff and I was like I
put out the number and like what I want
how much I want to lose by certain
malecon what number I want to get down
to and she was like like you put that on
I was like woah I put I post it now
everyone I'm friends with and they're
friends with see that and it makes me
feel more motivated to actually go out
and do it because now everyone's
expecting me to do that you know I love
the idea of being able to to tie it into
public accountability at the same time
like that's that's a baby step because
the big step that I ultimately want you
to take is it doesn't matter what other
people think about you like you're so
right like this I just want to use it as
my confidence hey guys I'm gonna do this
you can be a part of it or not a kind of
thing like right if you here's the thing
if you if you build your self-respect
up enough like doing the 30 day Zack
Zack Lang challenge in the morning and
they can tell you that for every goal
that you set your self-respect will be
so high that you don't need like sharing
it is motivation for them not for you
it's
okay use it now but like so so if
somebody doesn't call you out on it then
what happens you fall back to eating
Doritos and not not doing your diet and
not sticking through on your goals right
so it's a it's a crutch which is good to
use while you're injured but as you
build your strength which is just a
self-respect thing
then then you won't need them anymore
and sharing it becomes inspirational for
them you become you get permission other
people that go out and start their
journey too like why that I shared my
weight loss story not not for me - I
don't need people's comments to say to
keep me on my path I'm hoping that it's
an inspiration other people to start on
their journey - so the 30 days a Klang
challenge everyday 7 o'clock mark dot
axe here's a thing though if you don't
do it for one day you start to lose
self-respect this is why it's so
important that when you set a goal you
have to do it so be very careful about
the goals that you set for yourself when
you tell yourself you're gonna do
something you have to go off and do that
thing just doing that exercise for the
next 30 days wake up at 7 a.m.
exit off on the calendar and if you do
it every single day dude if you do it
every single day for the next 30 days
even when it's hard even with the
late-night partying whatever excuse
you're sick everything you're still
waking up you will feel so great about
yourself but in those 30 days now that
it's summer now that is difficult now
that nobody's forcing you to do it
you'll have so much more self-respect
for yourself
that'll make you feel like you can
tackle any other goal and that's the
point so like this is why now is the
best time to do it 30 days act laying
challenge I'm excited I'm excited share
that share that like day one here we go
guys 7:00 a.m. I did it day - 7:00 a.m.
I did at day 3 right and you can use
those people if you want as motivation
but also I guarantee you if you shared
every day people will be inspired by
that there's a ton of people who are in
your same situation slacking off over
the summer wanting to do more with their
life but they're not taking enough
action they want to wake up early they
want to attack the day but they're not
and just seeing you go after it even for
the next 30 days you'll inspire them to
go off and do it - what's up Mona I'm
studying music but I
some troubles with studying okay
sometimes I need to go to work and I
have other things to do and but I don't
know how to make time to study and
really keep stick to it to studying is
it important to you yeah it's really
important to me you know when something
is important to you you have to at least
for me I sketch I put it in my calendar
like I have my calendar Sunday to the
next Sunday and I block out time to do
different things like that I could say I
don't have time to do IG live today like
I've got a lot of stuff on my plate but
I made the time four times a week to go
live on Instagram to chat with you guys
because I think it's important if you
have work hours right you know when you
gonna be working you know you want to
spend time with family friends whatever
but when is study time gonna happen like
if it's Monday Wednesday Friday at night
like schedule it in treat it as a
priority if it's important to you then
you have to find the time on your
calendar to do it yeah that's really
something I need to do well but let's do
your schedule right now like how many
how many hours a week do you need to be
doing studying on a typical week I would
have to do 14 hours of studying okay and
and is that also like do you play an
instrument you have to practice as well
two hours a day so and everyday cuz with
saxophone is very important to play
every day yeah I used to play the
trumpet and I stopped high for a little
bit and then like I forgot everything I
forgot everything even like how to how
to put the lips on again I lost it so I
hear you so you need to do saxophone two
hours a day you have to practice two
hours a day and you need 14 hours of
studying during the week yeah okay so so
the let's let's tackle the two hours a
day all right where are those two hours
gonna come from to play saxophone like
as soon as you wake up when you go home
when you're gonna do it when I wake up
is the best time to do it because in the
morning I feel the most productive okay
and I really feel good okay I've done it
already today so I
and do other stuff okay so I fit it
would be great to do with in the morning
okay so you wake up and and what first
thing is play saxophone you brush your
teeth eat breakfast like what is the
morning schedule look like read or go to
work or something and but I would love
it to be just wake up brush teeth just
freshen up and then go practice what can
you do in the morning that will get you
inspired to play the saxophone listen to
music really gets me to be inspired so
how about if you wake up
you brush your teeth every morning don't
lie yes you do that's right so so how
about when you bright like brush your
teeth is you know it should be about the
length of a song so how about if you
while you're brushing your teeth you
play a song that gets you inspired to
then go play music so then today like
after this call make a playlist because
listening to the same song every morning
will lose its impact make a playlist
called the inspiring 50 of 50 songs that
when you hear you just you love them it
just makes you want to get on your
saxophone and play so then when you wake
up in the morning you're gonna you're
gonna wake up get your toothbrush play
randomly one of those 50 songs while you
brush your teeth and then go practice
for two hours I'll try this now you need
to wake up really enough that you can
still get to your job or your school or
anything else so you still have the two
hours to practice right now how about
the practice study in 14 hours a week
where we gonna put those for me ideally
would really be every day okay
like at night and the evening you want
one evening off like a Saturday night
off or Friday night off so like when
you're making the plan it has to be
realistic for you to stick to because if
you're basically say I never get a night
off then it'll be super hard to stick to
the schedule
you got to think about what time you get
home usually it's like 8:00 to 10:00 at
night you're you're studying or you're
trying to get ahead like I might even
bookmark 8:00 8:00 to 11:00 or 7:00 to
10:00 try to do three hours so that I'm
ahead so by the end of the week I've got
my 14 hours in and maybe I get my Friday
Saturday off yeah so and it will be more
funny than the time that I take off will
be more fun because I feel like they're
very productive during the other days
yeah if you man if you are productive it
makes you feel so good yeah prints off a
calendar like a weekly calendar you can
print one off after this to like what
the next week looks like today is
Wednesday so start from this Sunday this
Sunday you write the number 14 at the
top and then every day you you cut from
the 14 so if you did if you studied five
hours on Sunday now it's nine right and
then you did three hours on Monday now
it's six writing the goal is to hit that
14 as soon as possible like he might
even be Lee at Thursday Friday and
Saturday off because he just got so far
ahead if you look like you're ahead is
the best feeling ever
I'm feeling like you're behind and now
you need now you lose your entire Friday
and Saturday because you slacked off on
Monday Tuesday doing work that you know
wasn't really meaningful or important to
you and now you can't hang out with your
friends because you're so far behind
that sucks yes that's great thank you
very much if you want to know what
myself and other successful
entrepreneurs think about how to build
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every morning
for the next 254 mornings I will send
you a video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long absolutely for free that as
you watch them it'll help you build
unstoppable confidence check out the
link in the description below surround
yourself with greatness
realizing that any big endeavor is the
collection of a lot of small steps if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
with passion
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something serene if you want
to learn more about how to own your day
check out the video I made on the 5
morning routines that will transform
your life it's right next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you there
alright let's be honest how many of
y'all get up and you just get your day
started you don't have it written down
you won't have a strategy you don't have
a real plan